Film Courage: We talked about your process
for rewriting, let’s talk about rewriting
your own project or a project that you’re
initially hired to write, not someone else’s
first.
So what is your process?
You open up your computer you sit down, you’re
not really looking at prior pages before that
time (I assume)?
Mark Sanderson, Screenwriter: Rewriting as
you mean you’ve turned in a draft and they
gave me notes?
Film Courage: Yeah and they say “We like
this” but here are some notes and you’re
going back over from pretty much page one.
Mark: Sure…last month we just went through
that and we’ll probably go through that
next month because I just turned in something.
But last month the movie that is shooting
now I did rewrites.
The first draft was pretty solid the second
draft a few sequences changed because of particular
things and so there’s always a list of notes
specific of what needs to be changed and what’s
not quite working and needs to be finessed
and many things are sometimes technical without
getting into particulars.
But how a sequence is done you know it’s
always objects.
Well how would that person get that thing?
In my mind I write it be then there’s the
director’s mind who has to really shoot
the film and so that doesn’t come into play
until the director comes on board.
So then the notes come in from the producer
and then let’s say another producer who
hasn’t chimed in yet and then the director
and then they say “Okay.”
And the director is look at it hopefully about
how can I shoot this film with the money that
I have and your mind but I’ve never been
at the locations.
So then a lot of the notes changed “Well
we can only get this kind of place.
We need to tweet for that.”
And you go “Okay.”
And those are great.
Or don’t have them have this thing, have
them do (you know, I’m being vague), objects,
gu, whatever.
Things in the script.
So you can go through with almost a checklist
and go and make the fixes and hopefully like
I said with a solid treatment it shouldn’t
be like the house of cards implodes because
that’s not the place to be in development
when you’re like “Oh my gosh, I’ve got
to rewrite this whole thing.”
It’s still solid, A…B…and C still happens,
you get in and you start to…there is a sequence
that changed by its own nature and I agree
totally with the changes because nobody sets
out to make a bad movie and the changes are
not personal.
They’re like “Oh we thought of it and
it’s terrible.”
Somebody had to think of it, somebody had
to write it down, somebody had to create it
and then comes the realities of shooting a
movie.
And so my job at that point is to help the
make the movie.
My job is to help the producer and director’s
job make the film.
I’m not standing in their way, whatever
needs to be changed, it’s changed because
now we’re moving through development to
a reality phase (not this fantasy).
Motivations have to track, if they don’t
they say this is kind of weird, would that
character do this?
Maybe the other would flip.
You were saying about the strong, keeping
in mind the protagonist, well you gave that
to this other character, she should be doing
this.
You’re like “Oh, yeah you’re right.”
It’s just an easy fix because the character
then now is driving the story and it’s happening
to them rather not pushing it off to a co-star
or something.
And it’s very (I don’t want to say methodical)
but it is kind of methodical because after
doing this for so long it’s like “This
is what needs to be done.”
And double-checking, me going back through,
looking at all that, putting on revision mode
so everybody is on the same page, and then
they get it and the nicest thing is to hear…you
know do a quick polish let’s say a couple
day polish which is fixing little things that
the producer or director comes back and says
“That was a great job.”
I still get happy, I’m still happy about
hearing this because they don’t have to
say good job.
You job is you got paid but great job.
And on time because if you had take a week
that would push, they are already scouting
locations, they are doing things.
I don’t want to hold up that.
I want to get this turned around as fast as
I can also to get it off my plate, to open
up for other work.
You want to be a team player (as I say) an
ultimate collaborator at all steps in the
way.
And know your and know your place in the bigger
picture and so if go to the set if I’m not
working on the set I’m a guest.
I’m there, it’s nice.
I’ve been on sets that I worked writing,
I’ve also been on sets as a guests where
the director returned to me and he knew my
first spec how long it took to get it made
and he would turn to me and say “What did
you think about that take?”
And I’m like “Are you taking to me?”
And I’d go “Actually I thought it was
excellent.”
And he’d go “Me too.
Moving on.”
And you’re like “Aahhh.”
Film Courage: Angels singing in the background.
Mark: Yeah, that’s the great stuff you work
for and then there are the dark stormy nights
when you’re in despair and all these others
things.
Or that movie premiered at the Palm Springs
Film Festival, it opened and so we had a theater
full of 300 people and I’m sitting with
the stars and one of them I grew up as a kid
watching, he’s an academy nominee and he
turns over after the movie and he grabs my
arm and he says “Great job, Mark.”
And I’m like “He…he’s the guy with
the thing.
Who is he talking to?
Oh yeah, I wrote this movie.”
And then we get up and we do the Q&A and someone
asks the star (the lead), they say “You
know in that one scene, I love what you said
to your son it was so amazing.”
And an actor could have gone “Thank you
very much.”
And the star of the movie said “Well you
know people always say to actors what they
say is genius.
Without the writer…”
And he put his arm around me and he pulled
me close and he said “There would be nothing
to say.”
And that was another like “Huh?”
So you have these high of highs but it’s
not always like that.
Film Courage: Sure but that sound like that
worth doing.
Mark: It makes up for all the hard work and
stuff and you want to get to that point where
you’re on the set and you’re an equal
collaborator not just a fanboy going “Oh
my gosh!
Oh yeah I wrote this.
You’re right.”
And even more when I’ve had relationships
with the director who said I want you on the
set just as a good luck piece because we start
making changes, I want somebody to go “Whoah,
whoah, whoah!”
A lot going on on the set and people forget
and things fall through the cracks, well the
writer is going to go “Hey, hey, hey.
That line…you might not want to cut it because
it’s going to change things.”
But also they don’t want writers on the
set because they are changing things and you
don’t want to be “Aaarghh!”
Grumbling and walking around angry.
How could you be angry, you’re eating seared
Ahi at craft service and you got paid and
these wonderful actors are elevating your
material.
I mean, sounds good to me.
Film Courage: Sounds nice to me.
What’s day one of a rewrite like for someone
else’s work?
So they’ve given you notes, this is what
the other writer gave us, this is what’s
wrong.
Mark: It’s the same…you’re saying it’s
different than my own?
Film Courage: I guess then it is the same
process then>
Mark: Yeah, it’s chipping away, my own rewrites
is based upon notes of people that I trust
like say a spec.
I would give it to a circle of writer friends
who would give me notes.
I’d say “Hhmm…yeah…okay.”
And then go about the rewrite but it’s similar
to when you just check off the checklist and
say okay and get that draft done and push
each draft closer to the final realization
of the production draft.
Obviously your spec is a spec, it’s not
a production but in a rewrite my job is to
push that as quick as I can to get these changes
made and not hold up everything.
Film Courage: And you’re doing these changes
in numeric order in terms of the script page?
Mark: Yeah, I mean they are specific which
I love.
Other times I’ve had broad strokes like
well which I put in the book [A SCREENWRITER’S
JOURNEY TO SUCCESS: Tips, tricks and tactics
to survive as a working screenwriter in Hollywood].
Some of the notes are “The emotional highs
have to be higher and the lows have to be
lower.”
“What, what does that mean?”
And then they go “Okay, good luck.
See you in a week.”
And you’re like “I don’t know what you’re
talking about?”
And then if you come back and ask too many
questions “Why did we hire you again?
You don’t know what you’re doing?”
“Yes, I do.
Not all producers know how to talk to writers
properly.
They think they do and the really good ones
do where they like really get in there because
some of them are writers as well.
But the ones that just paint a broad stroke
and then “See you later and they’re busy
with their other projects and you have to
learn how to filter that and go “The emotional
highs and lows, what page?
What character, I don’t understand?”
And they go “You don’t understand?
Okay.”
And they pull the chute and you’re gone.
Film Courage: Is this LEAVING LAS VEGAS low,
MARY POPPINS high?
Mark: Exactly, it’s like what are we doing?
But the page specific notes, which then become
scene specific notes once the scene numbers
happen they are like “In this scene X, Y
and Z.”
And you’re okay, blah and this dialogue
here blah.
And so you just go in an do it, change, change,
and change and turn that draft in and hope
that’s closer and closer and closer.
What you don’t want is to be farther and
farther away.
That’s when you bring somebody else in.